おい見ろ……(低音)
これが……
メリケンサックだ。
[ｶﾁｯ]
[ｺﾝｯ]
こんにちはっ
ドクターーーーー
はじめだ。
ようやく私(わたくし)
Dr.はじめらしい
素晴らしい実験が、思いついたぞ！
今日実験に使う道具はこちらっ
見ろ、またこんなこと言ってる者がいるぞ〜
もうこれは言い逃れできんぞ
私は見てしまったぞ
この2文字を書いた意味がわかるか。
このハンガー
というわけでこの意味がわかりますでしょうか
これもう壊れないんだって！(可愛く)
いろんな色があったから3色買ってきたぞぉー
もうどれにも
“最強” “壊れない”×2って書いてある
もうどんだけ強いん！
このハンガー 最強 壊れない！
おいおいおいおい！(歓喜)
この私、Dr.はじめに
喧嘩を挑んでいるのかぁ！？
というわけで
壊れないと聞いたら壊したくなる男……
それで昔
失敗しているが
だが私は
壊れないと聞いたら
壊したくなる！！
というわけで
今日はこの最強の壊れないハンガーを
ぶっ壊していこうと、思う。
私はかつてゴルフクラブを破壊し、
炎上したことがある。
[ﾊﾟｷｯ]　うわっ！！
私は
可能な限りは炎上したくないので…
壊れないって聞いたらやっぱ僕
壊したくなっちゃうんでぇ
先にこの…ッkハンガーを作った本社に
連絡いたしましてぇ
ありがとうございます。
これで！！
これでお前らもう、これでほんとにあのこれで
炎上しないz…すよ。ほんとに。(？)
もう、いいんです。
これだって誰も…悪くないからね！
作った会社が！
いいですよって言って僕やってるんで
もうお願いします怒らないでください(涙)
私はいくつもの炎上を経験して
進化し続けているのだよ。
作った人に許可を取ればァ
まぁそうとも限りませんが
もうケース・バイ・ケースなんですよ
今回は実験の意味も込めて！
この最強に壊れないハンガー
どれだけ服をかけたら壊れるのか
検証していきたいと、思います。
では行こう！
[ﾋﾟｭﾝﾋﾟｭﾝ]
はい、というわけで
準備が整ったぞ お前たち
いまからここにッ！
最強の壊れないハンガーを
掛けるッッ
まぁ結局ぅ
使用用途を間違えるとダメなのでぇ
あくまで
“服とか物を掛ける”というアクションで
どこまで耐えれるか、実験していきたいと思います
これね、ほんと見た目がすごいんですよ
もう普通のハンガーとは思えないこの太さ！
や、これたぶん
相当頑丈っすねー
なんかここのボタン押すとこう……
ヒュッて
持ち運びも便利。
ぉん…ぱっと見傘だね傘
で、これどんな使い道があるかというとぉ
サーフィンとか、泳いだりした人の水着って
びしゃびしゃじゃないですか
濡れた服を引っ掛けても大丈夫だよっていう
丈夫なハンガーらしいです
はたしてどこまで俺の服に耐えれるのかなぁ(挑発)
ではさっそく掛けていこうと思います！
1枚目
[ﾄｼｬﾄｼｬﾄｼｬﾄｼｬ(楽器の音)]
まだまだハンガーは壊れません♡
2つ目
2つ目っていうか2着目だな
はいはいはい
はい
まだまだハンガーは壊れません♡
いやこれで壊れたらやばいけどね。
こっからちょっとずつ重くしてってやろう
じゃあ次は…
[ﾄｼｬﾄｼｬﾄｼｬﾄｼｬ(楽器の音)]
えぇっとぉホットバズーカじゃなくて…
えーやばい忘れた
インナーマッスルじゃなくて…
えっなんだっけ？マジで忘れた
次はこちらのヒートテックです！
3着目です
これで急にッ…
ズシッと重くなるけどもー
はいっ！
まだまだハンガーは壊れません
てわけで
またヒートテックつけていきましょぉ〜
ダブルヒートテック…
つけたら重いからね〜
4着目です
はい！
まだまだこんなんでは壊れるわけがありません
でも結構膨らんできましたよこれぇ
もう結構ハンガーってねぇ、思ったより弱くてぇ
これぐらい掛かると結構
ぐにゃんってなるやつとかも多いんですよ
もうちょっと掛けてきましょう
5着目です
よくありそうな服。
よくありそうな服を5着目に選んでいくぅ
服着せるのってめんどくさいですねぇ
服屋さんは大変です
はい！5着目つけました！
[ｶﾁｬﾝ]
まだまだ壊れまスンスンｓ(煽り)
や、なかなか重いと思います
6着目いきましょう
ふゔっふん(くしゃみ)
◎△＄♪×￥もうなんか普通の服にします…
もうちょっとやったら羽織る系にいきたいんでぇ
もうちょっと頑張ります！
オッケー6着目着せましたぁ
もう手で持ってても重いレベルだけど
全然余裕☆
6着でも問題なくいけますね
ではそろそろちょっとずつ
羽織る系をつけていきましょう
7着目です
羽織る系とか楽なんだよなぁ
普通にオシャレだ
普通にコーディネート動画みたいになってますけど
無事完了しました
8着目です
わ、普通になんか
私服晒してるみたいで恥ずかしいな
だがこれもー
最強のハンガーの実力を試すためー
しゃーないしゃーない
はい8着目も全然大丈夫です
いやっもう だいぶ重いっすよこれ！
もう、1kg,2kgぐらいな気がするなぁ
では続いて、9着目いきましょう
これは私が、着るのが恥ずかしくて
買ったものの
なかなか着れなかった服だぁ
やばいもう俺のファッションショーじゃんもうこれぇ
これもう 重さどうこうより
服が重ねれるか 重ねれないか
そこの戦いになってきてるなぁ
あーでも大丈夫そうっすねぇ
はい、というわけで 9着目も無事着れましたぁ
やーこれねー、たぶんね
普通のハンガーだと結構やばいと思う
普通に折れてるよ？たぶん
では10着目いきます
ダメだぁ…服だとぶっ壊せねぇのかぁ？
はい！
あ、全然余裕。
10もいける
ガチめに無限説あるぞこれ やばいぞー
では11着目です
11着目は重いやつを選ばせていただいたぞー
はたして貴様に耐えれるかどうかというところだな！
はっはっは
えっすごいよ！うわ！重ぉ！(興奮)
待って、もう、もうやばい もうやばい
普通にここ持つと
この手が痛いレベルです もう。
いや！
甘えたことを言っている場合ではない
私の目標は…
壊すこと(キリッ)
もうどんどんいきますからねぇ？
では12着目です
もう全然余裕
1回ここで閉ｍ…
あっ待ってなんか入ってる　[ｶｻｶｻ]
[ｶｻｶｻ]
[ｼﾞｰ]
はい、12着目完成です！
えー まだいけるなぁ
では13着目いきます
ちょっとガラが悪いです
YABEE！
はちきれそうだぁ！
13枚も服重ね着することないっすからねぇ…
はい全然大丈夫です
すごい、もう、
うわぁ！！
やばい！！
待って、重い
重すぎて、重すぎてすごい
もうここまできたらどんどんいきましょう
14着目です
こんな重いのきたら大変だぁ(ワクワク)
いけるかぁ？
うわ！
あっ待って
バキッつった×5
いまバキッつったよねぇ？
え、なんなんなんなんなに
なになになに
や、なんかバキッつったけど
まだなんかいけてそうっすねぇ
たぶん
たぶん大丈夫です！
というわけで次は15着目です
もうやばい
でかい服を準備しないといけないんすよ
もう絶対タイミングおかしいんですけど
セーター着せてみましょう。
セーターなんか伸びるイメージがあるんでぇ
意外と大丈夫な気がします…
あーでもなんとか着れてますね
ふっくｓ(くしゃみ)
もうやばいこれ以上でかい服がない
ってぐらいお前着込んでるわねぇ
もう人よ？ほぼ
[ｼﾞｨｯ]
もう も、もうやばいよぉ
うーわぁっ！
やばい！
何kgだこれぇ
[ｶﾀｶﾀ]
ああ待って！！
もうダメだ 重すぎて掛けれん
ばったしぃ！！(？)
大変ですもう重すぎて
ハンガーに掛けるのが一苦労なレベル
ウッ(掛け声)
すごいな…
来ることまで来たぞ！
壊してぇ〜〜
ここまでくると壊してぇ〜〜
えーでもこのサイズになるとねー
着れる服がほぼないんですよ
ここはなんとかオーバーサイズの服で
かわしていきたいもんだ
え？すごいよ。無限なの？
マジですごいよ
待て、待って
見てくれ
普通はこう、なんかちょっと綺麗な横なのに
もう もうすごい曲がり方してるぞこれー
大丈夫かー(棒)
わああああああああああああああ
そういうことか。
これたぶん…こう…あったじゃないすか。ずっと
で、こうやってすごい重りが
かかってかかってかかってやばそうになるとぉ
[ﾊﾟｷｯ]
強制的にストッパーが外れて、こう、
収納される仕組みになってるみたいです
相当のぉ服が掛かってたんで
めちゃくちゃ重かったと思うんですけどもー
よくあそこまで耐えたと思います
あぁあ〜
こういう壊し方すると炎上するんだろ〜
なっ☆
はい、というわけで
これは普通の使い方をしていては絶対壊れません。
ナゼナラ！
[ﾊﾟｷｯ]　ぅん！(掛け声)
じゃあもう逆にこの状態の耐久度調べてみましょう
もうここの強さは充分わかったんでぇ
あとはハンガーとしても大事な
吊り下げの力
どんだけ吊れるかっていうのを
ちょっと試したいと思います
もう服吊ってもたぶん
ギャンッってなるのはわかったんで、
僕自身がァ 実際にぶら下がってみようと、思います
ではこの子自体の
ハンガーとしてのその、吊り上げ力を
私自身の身体を使って
実験してみようと思う。
ではいきます
これで、俺が、浮いたら、マジで、すごい、商品だと…
思うっ
うぇっ？
[ﾊﾟｺﾝ]
オゥッ
わああああああああああああああ
待って
やばい
鼻折れた
たぶん鼻折れた
これたぶん金具ですね
ここたぶん曲げればまた使えると思うんですけどぉ
ま、人は無理にしろ
相当の数の服は、掛けることができるっていうことが
わかりました
こういう動画撮れるのねぇ もう
無許可でね、壊すと怒られるんでぇ
許可いただけて
ほんとに素敵な会社だなって思いました
ありがとうございました
[鼻をすする音]
鼻折れたな